hello how's it going bros - booty pot so
I asked you on facebook to leave me a
voice message and today I'm gonna review
them I have no idea what you will send
me but I'm very excited let's go
how's it going Bozeman and the Ducks are
coming so someone try to impersonate me
and a duck choke him awesome this is
going great so far why did I expect
normal messages I wish I could have more
time to fully express my gratitude Thank
You Felix for always making your videos
and making me much thank you oh that was
a really sweet message thank you
I don't Nick I didn't expect nice ones
all right what do we got here please
don't panic don't look behind you I
don't have to because I can see through
the lens that I'm totally fine right
nice fried bits it's great that this
really show said the people who watch my
videos are very cultural and
intellectual people this clearly shows
very clearly so far I'm really impressed
well that was sick bro
well I am a pigeon and proud that makes
me a proud pigeon hooray artistic
penguin thank you for calling in
what the [ __ ] was that Jesus Christ how
do you even make a sound like that what
is that you sound like you're swallowing
yourself I'm horny a [ __ ] here I've got
that that's to impress senpai so I just
record myself jumping of done
hello do you love me
no I love you yes hashtag crush mama
okay
Rauf is from Poland why did I say that
hi build your fan since I was really
young and I just want to tell you thank
you because you helped me in my dark
days and just keep doing what you do
because you're awesome thank you you too
man where ever I want him hey no man you
want you want this devil of a dog take
him please take it he looks nice because
he's sleeping and what that [ __ ] are you
doing I want to get rid of him so bad
look at him look at this idiot nice one
man yeah no that's awesome thank you so
much for your message no no no no I'm
not objective hi purify in Brazilian
Portuguese we don't say I love you we
say Jacopo Jessica and I think that's
beautiful
Jacques abortion bla jackaboy Jessica
Jacopo Shabbat jackaboy Jessica jackaboy
Shabbat 100% hi Felix I just want to
thank you for making me happy Burke is
from Hungary Hungary Hungary brofist
right back but the boys what did he ask
for the voice messages but the voice me
it's Arnold Schwarzenegger trying to ask
me what a voice messages but the voice
may be back please notice me
yes hey can you answer me this that is
white and song slave attack that's great
attack glad we got that cleared out in
PewDiePie do you or do not as
jacksepticeye needs this is your mom
what's wrong with you
foods two potato people they have mercy
as you know they're also Edgar and Maya
you got two they just erased your
memories you have to get her back have
to beg techno music the background very
convincing man you got me [ __ ] is wrong
with you guys oh my god no stop trying I
think it would be fun to do more of
these I had a lot of fun so record me a
voice message not more than 10 seconds
and send it to me with a hashtag voice
pills like the ones that are funny and
I'll be sure to find those that's it for
now thank you for so much for all the
voice messages a lot of fun and leave a
like if you enjoyed
enjoy sounds and I will see you bros in
the next video stay awesome bros man
kissing i got weird fast a name and okay
it's I'm happy for them this
I was too manly men